the Joe Rogan experience there's a lot
of people that are born male and female
I could imagine being a girl and having
some boring ass [ __ ] dude trying to
stick brutal oh yeah everywhere you go
and then say hey you know you should
post smile a little maybe oh I hate that
move is that everywhere I don't know
maybe must've guys do do that they make
us look bad
really dumb guy and a dumber girl yeah
maybe it would work
oh I'm sorry it doesn't self-conscious
about my smile oh you got a beautiful
smile you things huh yeah okay thanks
you're like those two are made for each
other yeah you guys deserve looking
audience they really should both go into
the woods and get eaten by wolves that's
what should happen right in the real
like if if we really were trying to make
a better human race it would be more
variables isn't there be more more traps
that's true that's true but we got to be
nice you know well we should be nice we
should be nice but sometimes I think
it's just genes like sometimes sometimes
people just have knucklehead genes well
yeah sometimes I see people you know
you're walking down the sidewalk and
seen in somebody's living room and there
are 8,000 pounds they're watching two
and a half minute a bowl of Cheetos in a
beer you're like you're kind of a waste
of life like no offense you do deserve
life you have a right to live but I'm
out here trying to write jokes and I'm
driving from gig to gig I'm doing pods
I'm going gay whatever it is at least
I'm trying something at least I have a
little ambition you're moving
yes experiencing life yeah even if you
send a tweet out at least like you put
something into the world even though it
could be horrible but like this guy I'm
just like you're just waiting to die
you're just counting the minutes till
you go there's something about like and
then they have kids so they're like now
you brought even more [ __ ] into the
world okay you're all right but like you
know you see you're a dad of nine or
whatever and then have 80 kids 80 kids
that's a lot of testosterone it's
putting in you but yeah so you probably
teach your kids like hey mix-up with
your life yeah well they can only use
electronics for a certain amount of time
good for you
they you know and they they're involved
in activities they play sports they do
things I think you gotta do stuff with
them too and also they have to see that
you're doing yes a parent like one of
the things that kids get out of you
they see you live by example yes that's
important totally and and then on the
flip side though I get selfish and I go
well it's a good thing this fat [ __ ] is
sitting in a Barcalounger all night
because now I get to go and do some with
my life and he's out of my way that and
you also feel better you know right come
home from a hard day of getting after it
yeah and see that fat slob sitting
further TV laughing really hard at Big
Bang Theory yeah okay buddy I'm [ __ ]
better than you you hate to say it but
that's why I like sometimes I think us
being we're under six foot and that a
bummer when you love to be six foot I
don't know man I kind of something about
me being short has helped me be more
ambitious that's what I'm saying benefit
it's probably benefit to it right right
that's you want it that's why I like it
sounds bad but ugly people are funny
it's a lot of ugly people on it you got
a break they did some study where kids
are more trust ugly people less so it's
not just being shallow it's kind of
innate oh yeah well imagine being a
woman who has terrible genetics and
there's probably someone listening to
her right now and it's not a goddamn
thing you can do about that it's not
your fault you got a giant Fred
Flintstone head chair try to make your
way through this life with the football
players body oh yeah I got some moles on
you you got everything wrong yeah it's
falling out yeah yes stubby fingers at
jowls you turkey weird elbows and it's
out there just trying to get after it
yeah and nobody wants it yeah that's why
I love an ugly lady who's horny because
that's my favorite I love that I'm not
saying to bang I mean I have but I love
an ugly horny lady because she's I feel
like we have a lot in common
I have a buddy mine and his favorite is
a girl with kind of a Mugsy face but a
killer Bob those gals go to work that
hits a nerve in a guy because he like
it's attainable and she's probably like
got like normal self esteem she's not
entitled she's at the gym every day all
day doing squats yeah it's the same with
meathead boring guys who are like I got
to get some traps cuz I got no skills
that ended in a talking wise yeah just
find some dingbat chick and shoot those
[ __ ] loads into her yeah you hope
that the all those groups meet like you
dumb work
and asteroid yeah we're there or that
yeah it's I mean but something like
things bats have kids and those kids go
goddamn my parents were stupid I'm gonna
do something with my life that's a good
point that happens a lot I know a lot of
really [ __ ] smart people of idiots
for parents
[Applause]